بعد سنوات من حرماله من التعليم الاساسي
تجهز بطوله محمد النازحه التي تعيش في
مخيم خارج القدس وابنها نوح للحاق بمدرسه
تقدم التعليم الاساسي لاطفال النازح هذا
المخيم بخطوات سريعه ينضم نوح عبد القادر
ذو تسع سنوات الى مئات من اطفالي هذا
المخيم الذين يبداون صباحهم المدرسيه فيه
بوجبه فطور قد تعينهم على الجلوس لساعه
على مقاعد الدراسه ولمدرسه عباره عن خمس
غرف يجلس فيها نحو 600 تلميذ يدرسون
المواد الاساسيه في الفترتين الصناعيه
والمسائيه وتقول النظيفه حسينا صاحبه
المبادره والعامله في مجال دعم النازحين
ان هذه الخطوه تاتي في اطار جهودها لدعم
النازحين حيث يعيشوا الاف الاطفال من
المشردين بدون تعليمه
قرانيه ثم انشات هذه المدرسه دعمي اطفال
النازحين الذين يعانون من الاميه ادعوا
جميع القادرين الى دعمها هؤلاء الصغار
لبناء مستقبلهم
ويعملوا في المدرسه اثنا عشر مدرسا متطوعا
يدرسون المواد الاساسيه اعتمادا على منهج
وزاره التعليم صوماليه
[موسيقى]
وادعو كل من يستطيع ان يساعده هؤلاء
الصغار الذين بداوا يندمجون في المجتمع
ووصلوا الى مستويات عاليه من التعليم
الاساسي
كنت في البيت وكنت العب فقط واتم الحاق
بهذه المدرسه وانا سعيدنا الان لاني
استطيع ان اكتب وان اقرا
على تعليم بفضلها هذه السيده ونتمنى ان
تتحسن احوالنا بشكل عام ونجد مساعدات
دائمه
على هذه المبادره التي اتت بنتائج مشجعه
على نشر هذه الفكره واصالها الى المخيمات
المجاوره عبد الرحمن العربيه
[موسيقى]